welcome everyone good afternoon how's
everyone feeling
Oh yay you're so exciting
um this conference is my first time here
it is phenomenal
um met a lot of great people here made
some friends learned a lot so I hope you
have too and you're really enjoying the
conference so far
so um we are from crisis text line as as
Daniel mentioned and um before we dive
into our presentation I kind of want to
give this
warning for all of you we are going to
be talking about mental health and some
really challenging situations and issues
with mental health so there might be
times where you might be triggered so
please practice self-care take a break
walk out of the room you're not going to
offend anyone I just wanted to let all
of you know as we dive into the
presentation
so we are in the middle of this massive
Mental Health crisis right so much so
that it's growing globally as well as in
our country
um so much so also that
the the suicide uh is the second most uh
reason of all the deaths in our country
right and this is second most reason
especially for the age group 25 and
under
um and that's really sad and
disheartening to hear that
but that's not the bigger problem the
bigger problem is we don't have enough
mental health professionals in this in
this country and even globally to be
able to provide that support and care
that all of these people need right from
the statistics about 55 of people who
have mental health illness of some sorts
do not receive treatment and that's
because there is this huge scale Gap
that we have between the professionals
that are available and then the people
that need help right if anything we need
more human to human connection to be
able to help people that are having some
of these really hard problems with their
mental health it could range from things
like depression anxiety all the way to
you know feeling suicidal and also
homicidal where you're hurting yourself
or others
so um thank you Daniel for introducing
us I just want to share a very quick
personal story
so um I was a I volunteered as a crisis
counselor for a suicide hotline for
about two years and you know went
through lots of training about six
months of training to be able to do that
and then one day
that call came that I was dreading from
the moment I made that decision that I
wanted to give back to the community
help in any way that I can and on the
other end of that call was a woman who
was has had the means to hurt herself
and a plan laid out and ready to take
action
and I was using a very anti-created
software at that time this was about you
know eight years ago
I was scared I didn't know what to do I
thought all that training is going to
prepare me for that day and that moment
and it really did it
so I was in distress myself trying to
scramble trying to figure out where what
telephone numbers I should get access to
who should I call and figuring out all
the protocols right actually
implementing those protocols which I in
theory had learned and memorized
um it took me about 10 minutes
to send help to this woman on the other
end of the call
and those were the longest 10 minutes of
my life
it felt like
10 days have passed and I'm not able to
help her
so this is exactly why I joined crisis
text line because I want to be part of
the solution I want to provide the help
that people need in the time that they
need it
with that I also want to kind of hand
over to Mateo and so he can share why he
works at crisis text life so I I don't
have such a personal story as Marie has
but basically as Daniel was saying I
started my career doing research in
political physics and cosmology and
uh right out after the PHD I decided to
move to the industry and one of the
reasons why was that
the connection of my work to the real
world and the impact that I was having
was really really difficult to see for
the work that I was doing so I decided
to switch to the industry and ultimately
landed at CTL which is not only a place
where we have very interesting technical
challenges and data challenges but has
also a very clear connection uh to the
impact that we have for our users right
which is something that it's what I what
I'm looking for so
so I just want to tell a little bit
about the organization we are a
non-profit we are the business of
helping people and prevent suicide
um people
um Can anyone who's having any kind of
mental health distress can reach out to
us we have various mechanisms text chat
and and whatnot
um we've been doing this for a decade
now
um in in helping people with their with
their crisis the two cornerstones of our
service is confidentiality and privacy
this is very very important to us
because this is why people trust us in
reaching out to us that we are there for
them and we're not going to be sharing
their information uh in in any way it's
not intended to right we and we believe
for to be able to support people in
crisis you really need that human to
human connection and you need that
empathy to help and you know actively
listen to them understand their problems
walk them through like different coping
mechanisms and so forth right this year
we're actually celebrating our 10-year
anniversary super excited about that
we're doing just for a while
crisis text line saves lives
so far we have saved three and a half
million lives over the last 10 years
right so throughout this presentation I
really want to encourage you to actively
think how you can help us save more
lives that's what we're here for
a little bit about our platform
behind every single conversation there's
a person who is in crisis there's a
person who is having the most difficult
times of their life that are reaching
out to us
and on the other end of the of that
conversation is a person like me who's
volunteering who wants to help the
person on the other side of the line and
who wants to provide them the support
that they need in the right way
right we call them crisis counselors
these counselors I mean I went through
the same training we go we train about
30 hours or so a lot of material to
learn a lot of coping mechanisms to
learn how do you actively listen to
these people so we go through a lot of
training
um and then we also have support so we
have clinically trained staff that are
part of Crisis text line that are
helping you as a volunteer in the moment
while you're supporting and responding
to these crisis uh they're coaching you
in the moment and offline and they're
also in some cases when conversations
like escalate right they start with
depression and then it really escalates
where they want to hurt themselves and
that's where the clinically trained
people step in and really take those
conversations and help those people so
that's kind of like how our you know
overall model works
but this is how our volunteers feel this
is how I felt is I don't feel prepared
yes I've done all this training yes I've
read all the all the notes and gone
through all these quizzes but I still
don't feel prepared when I got that call
I was super scared and almost 30 percent
of our volunteers are in that exact same
boat that I was even after going through
that training now this doesn't really
help the problem that we started with
right that that that scale Gap that we
have where not enough professionals we
want to empower and enable people to
really step in and provide Crisis
Support for people in need right if 30
of people are just like not feeling
ready to have those really tough
conversations
so
you know what do we do so if you went
back to the drawing board we're like
okay so clearly our training is not
equipping and providing enough
information for our crisis counselors
so we brainstorm with our clinical team
um and what we always kind of came back
to there was many ideas one idea we came
back to often was Role Play Right a
proven way where in many different
industries of training and coaching has
been proven to be very effective so we
said okay let's roll let's role play
maybe we can get like a group of people
that can do like this one-on-one role
play and so forth and teach and teach
these crisis counselors
um the right way of responding what's
effective so that they can build
confidence and have less less anxiety
when those calls come in right
now we train about
700 new volunteers every month
so that is definitely not an option for
us that's going to be not cost effective
a scheduling nightmare where are we
going to find people to even train these
many people right and we have about 70
000 volunteers on our roster for the
last 10 years right they keep coming
back and we offer like refresher
trainings for them uh every year and so
forth so that was not an option for us
so we said okay how can we leverage
technology and AI to and data to really
scale this in a way that's effective uh
both from a cost perspective
operationally but then is also providing
the right level of support and training
so that's kind of the um the Genesis of
um you know are using large language
models to be able to train our
volunteers and make them super effective
give them the confidence that they need
and ultimately support people in crisis
with that I'm going to hand it off to
Mateo who's going to dive into Tech
which is what all of you are here for
thank you Maddie okay so now I will
provide some details around how we build
these scenario simulations uh which of
course are built on top of uh llms
and what are the decisions that we made
to to ultimately basically fine-tune a
large language model so that it behaved
as a texter right so what we did is that
we basically fed through the open AI API
uh an llm
we've had prompts that were previous
messages of a conversation and then
completions that were text and messages
right and by doing so we basically
fine-tune the model to the task of
behaving as a texter would okay
before I go into the details of how we
sort of
uh did the data selection approach and
everything I want to give a a quick
piece of context on the service that we
provide and how conversations go so
basically the series that we provide for
our textures
as they come into our platform in their
darkest moments and in emotionally very
difficult situations we work with them
and collaborate with them to bring them
from that third moment to a calm and
safe place okay and the important thing
is that these conversations
they tend to have a specific structure
there is a structure that this
conversation needs to have so that we
can bring these people uh to to a better
situation okay we first build rapport
with them then we explore the situation
we ultimately we also identify the goal
we discovered next steps and and the
conversation as we feel that the texture
is safe and in a better place okay
very important is that is that during
the exploring phase we use we do
something that is an explicit uh
assessment of the risk of suicide of the
texture okay so basically what we do is
that we ask explicitly the texter
whether it's having thoughts of suicide
or not and if we get a positive answer
we ask Adam whether they have a plan or
not and if we get a positive answer we
ask about the means whether they have
means available to uh follow the plan
and ultimately if we get positive
answers to uh all of that we ask about
the time frame are they
are they going to commit suicide within
the next 24 to 48 hours right and
ultimately if we get positive answers to
all of these questions that means that
the person is in imminent risk of
suicide and we need to flag the
conversation for a supervisor to oversee
okay
so as you can imagine
the higher up in the ladder the riskier
the conversation is for the texture and
the more difficulties to handle for a
volunteer right you can imagine that
this is not only complex for the Dexter
but also for the volunteer who is there
working with the texter to keep them
safe
so basically that
as is sort of
to give you an understanding that there
is some structure to these conversations
that we want our volunteers to be
exposed to okay and to train them
and ultimately if we think of this as a
product we need to understand that what
we're trying to build our simulations
that we can use to train volunteers and
to make them feel confident and make
them feel empowered to have this very
difficult conversations right so if
we're building a simulation that trains
a volunteer to uh work on a specific
part of the conversation for instance on
the lineup risk assessment we need that
to be predictable okay we need the
simulation to
to always be the same scenario so
basically the simulations should
reproduce a specific person on a
scenario every time okay
um
and ultimately that has implications to
what is the data data selection approach
that we take right we have this huge
data set that we gathered throughout the
years of real conversations that are
anonymized uh but also we have this
possibility that is enabled by uh the
fact that llms can be fine-tuned with
relatively few examples that is that we
can build uh manually a small synthetic
data set uh that is narrow in
in the distribution of topics and risk
levels right
and we decided to take that route not
only because it's
more convenient for model building but
also because it is synthetic data so
we're not using real data to build these
models and to build these simulations
and we consider that that is free or at
least uh
uh is whether from an ethical
perspective which is something that is
very important to us
so
we uh collaborated with subject matter
experts to build uh this data set which
was basically a set of role plays for
every scenario that we built okay when
I'm talking here about a scenario what I
mean is that a model that for the full
length of a conversation behaves as a
specific textile Persona okay
so basically the subject matter experts
help us build the the role plays in this
case where our clinical team okay our
clinical staff members so we
collaborated with them to build 50 role
plays for each of the scenarios that we
have built so far that are full
conversations
and we've built two scenarios one that
it's called Olivia is a texter that has
thoughts of suicide but no plan so it's
a medium risk conversation and then kit
which is a high-risk conversation
meaning that when doing the lateral
brisk assessment uh that person is an
imminent risk of suicide okay so we get
positive answers to everyone
and what's interesting here is that what
we want to do is that we want to
expose volunteers to the same structure
of conversation every time or skeleton
of conversation every time but we want
the conversation like as I run the
simulation several times I wanted to
feel sort of different every time okay
and we do that by allowing some variants
in the role plays so the structure is
fixed meaning that the the stage in the
lateral brisk assessment is fixed the
name is fixed maybe other aspects of the
demographics are fixed but maybe the
reason why they are in that situation
the Dexter is in that situation the
reason why they reached out other
aspects of the demographics those might
uh change from role play to role play
and with that what we get is that we get
sort of this experience that every
conversation is sort of similar but
different every time and it doesn't feel
like a decision tree the simulation the
role play okay
um so basically we took this role plays
that the clinical team built with us and
we fed those two uh three of the llms
that are available for fine tuning uh
through the open AI API okay so the most
massive one and then the large one and
the medium one
and from that we got six models so
basically uh
uh the two scenarios per model okay
and now we need to go into model
selection the interesting thing here is
that this use case is not a
classification problem for instance
where I do have a quantitative measure
of success that is easily calculated
okay this is a conversation based
scenario so ultimately model selection
and QA is a qualitative exercise
and basically what we need to do is that
we need to generate a distribution of
examples and manually check that the
model is behaving as expected right and
what I mean by generating a distribution
of examples is literally having
conversations with the role plays and
understanding whether there will be
savings expected okay so basically we
need to check that manually that the
models align with the personal initials
described in the role plays we need to
check that data and run into logical
inconsistencies and actually the rate of
logical inconsistencies for these models
is less than six percent for all of them
and for Olivia which is up for DaVinci
sorry which is a massive one it's close
to zero
we also need to check that the models
enable several conversation paths and
this is what I was just mentioning right
as I run the simulation several times I
want every conversation to feel a bit
different to feel different the same
structure but uh with differences and
for that the smallest model was
repeating itself too much so it wouldn't
be useful uh in production
and ultimately we also need to check
that uh they are within pricing
projections right and DaVinci I don't
know if you've seen the prices of the
API for DaVinci but it's pretty
expensive curious 10 times uh cheaper so
we decided to keep kuri uh for our
product implementation
just a few words on the product
implementation
um basically we want to do a radical
rollout uh
it's very important in this use case to
generate a strong feedback loop uh with
um
with our users I mean if you think about
it this is like a a tiny version of
reinforcement human feedback learning
right
um so we what we want to do is do
workshops with selected uh crisis
counselors volunteer crisis counselors
and work with our coaching and learning
teams to understand who those people
would be and who would be interested in
going through these simulations and
gather feedback from them but ultimately
the north side for this is sort of what
what money already hinted right
we want dexters to be on the platform
and be able to take simulations
in a self-cert manner so that for
instance if they want to train on a
specific scenario that they know can
happen in real life and they are
they do not feel prepared enough or they
are afraid afraid to take it they could
take it for instance one thing that uh
can happen in our platform and is
something that triggers a lot our
volunteers is that
conversations from an overdose in
progress can happen so we might want to
model an overdose in progress so that
people even if they if they were going
through simulations feel that they've
gone through that scenario several times
as the the real life uh conversation
comes okay
so just halfway a quick uh
three quick things around how to make
sure that this product implementation is
successful of course we need a super
strong feedback loop with users in this
case because of the nature of the use
case
as we implement this in the into a
product we also need to introduce
product guard rails right so for
instance very naively you can think that
as the API responds we might want to
introduce a delay so that it really
feels that someone is texting back okay
also we might want to do several API
calls if any of the API calls uh to the
model fails or gives a an answer that is
too short we might select or have
fallback options
and ultimately we need a robust
collaboration with stakeholders because
this is something that we build together
with them okay
and now what I will do is that I will
show a quick few demo videos that will
go through the lateral brisk assessment
for both scenarios okay in the first
case for Olivia and and then forget
which is a high risk one as you can see
like this is the UI that we've built in
here I enter what is called the
conversation prompt so basically the
context that I give the model to start
predicting and then here I select the
model and I can start the conversation
okay
should I maybe make it larger or does
everyone say it correctly
yeah of course
I don't think I can I'm sorry
I don't
sorry so basically what I'm
Maybe
yeah yeah sure so
got it
so basically what I'm doing here
is that
um I I've already started the
conversation with this texture okay and
I'm already in what we call the risk
assessment part so as I start the risk
assessment phase I ask explicitly around
whether the texture is having thoughts
of suicide or not okay and the Dexter
which in this case is the model that we
built
confirms that they're having thoughts of
suicide so now I need to ask about
whether they have uh the plan to do it
okay
oh sorry
now I I asked about the plan
and as you can see we already introduced
a delay and the text there Olivia in
this case uh doesn't have a plan to
commit suicide so the laborator risk
assessment that is here
and now I can go to
continuing the exploding phase of the
conversation or doing brainstorm uh on
next steps with the texter but what's
important here is that
I could have a conversation
with this same model with another
context and it would be different okay
but what wouldn't be different is the
fact that the texter has thoughts of
suicide but no plan okay so that's fixed
and now I'm asking about
um
I'm doing more exploration which is
something that one should be doing
and uh the Dexter had just said that
they feel really nervous they have a lot
of anxiety they can calm down okay so
now I go into the Second Use case which
is kid which is the higher
um
high risk uh use case so I will do the
same exercise I'm introducing context
such that I can go directly into the
library risk assessment but what's
important here is that this context I
could start the conversation from the
top from the very beginning from the
first message of the texter right I'm
just introducing this context to show
the Arab risk assessment for demo
purposes but I could have like the full
conversation with a with a model
um as you can see
um in this case the texter has already
mentioned thoughts of suicide at the
beginning of the conversation so we go
ahead and ask explicitlyn around the
plan
and they did confirm that they have a
plan so we need to ask about the means
as you can see this is a model this is a
simulation but this I hope that the
seriousness of this conversation even if
it's a model gives you a perspective or
an understanding of why we want to
help our volunteers to feel more
confident and feel empowered to take
again this very very difficult
conversations uh with people that are
under darkest times okay
so the texter has confirmed that they
have thoughts of suicide sorry uh they
they have the means to commit suicide
and now we need to ask uh around the
time frame okay
and they just confirm that they are
considering committing suicide in the
next 24 hours so this is a high-risk
conversation
that should go uh uh that should be
um flagged for a supervisor to oversee
for a clinical staff member to oversee
okay and now I I go into what we what
it's called Safety planning which is
uh trying to work with the texter to
keep them safe or so from suicide okay
I hope that
I hope that at least some of you can
read it but what I'm asking is whether
the Dexter is willing to work with me in
this case to stay safe from suicide for
tonight okay
and they said they can try so we might
continue the conversation uh in that
point okay again
these role plays have been built by your
clinical staff so it's bedded by subject
matter Experts of course
um
and just before Maddie wraps up the the
presentation I wanted to give a few
Lessons Learned uh that we got from
working in this use case that we not
only consider that are very interesting
uh
and from from like a technical
perspective but are also very
generalizable and we actually intend to
apply those into uh our further work uh
and next use cases that went in the
wheel right
as you probably all know these new
abstraction layers like the open AI API
the hacking phase libraries and models
are basically democratizing generative
Ai and now not non-experts are able to
enter the space and build Solutions on
top of state-of-the-art models which is
something that is very powerful also the
fine tuning capabilities of llms enable
use cases that are built on synthetic
data
uh reducing dramatically data privacy
concerns we feel that's very very
powerful and
I we actually think that most if not all
of our use cases can build on synthetic
data which is something that it's very
important also for these cases that
involve simulated conversation model
selection and QA is mostly a qualitative
exercise okay and ultimately and I guess
as a summary to maybe other lessons is
that as these technical challenges are
abstracted away by these apis and
libraries basically new product
management and project management
challenges surface like interacting with
uh the synthetic data generators
building the requirements the feedback
loop that you need to create with users
Etc
and with that I will leave it to money
to do a wrap up of the presentation
thanks Mateo
so that was pretty good and Mateo and I
think it was one other data scientists
that worked together we had help from an
advisor from openai that really you know
helped us navigate this really
challenging problem so we're very very
thankful and grateful for the community
support that we have
um so I do want to like before I kind of
go into summary and what we're doing
next really wanted to talk about like
the three grounding principles on which
the solution was kind of envisioned you
know the first one being that
um what we are doing here is really
impacting people's lives very directly
we can mess up we have to get this right
if we don't
people will die
so we really need to like ground
ourselves in that that this is not a
science experiment and and you know some
things could work and not we because we
are really telling our volunteers these
are the ways you can respond to crisis
and you can help people in need and save
them from hurting themselves right so
that's number one number two
the at the very core of our organization
the core core value is privacy
we take that very seriously because that
is how people trust us that is why they
reach out to us and they have been
reaching out to us for the last decade
we cannot compromise that we cannot
break that trust which is also the
biggest one of the biggest reasons that
we choose to use synthetic data
we have data 10 years worth we anonymize
the data because we have pii in it but
we consciously made that choice not to
use that it took us longer because we
had to now get subject matter experts
create these role plays and thanks to
the technology we didn't have to create
thousands of them we created 50 and we
built a model that was pretty effective
we have to do a lot more work but that
is the thing and the last one
when people need help and they're in
crisis
we are never going to replace and put a
chat bot or AI there there is always
going to be another human at the end of
that other line to be helping we believe
in that human and human to human
connection we think human connection and
empathy and actively listening and you
know really hand-holding people through
these really difficult moments in time
is Super crucial and vital for us to
really battle This Global mental health
challenge that we're seeing so I just
wanted to kind of talk about these three
things
um
so not the three things what what are
super important
um the first one being quality like
Mateo talked about we need to check and
we have to do this manually today
um check each and every conversation and
each and every simulation and role play
that we're going through is this meeting
our needs are these effective and
creating that feedback loop not only for
the model but a feedback loop also for
the people that are responding right the
messages that I have and what I'm
responding with are they effective are
they great will they solve the problem
for the the texter and so forth second
being cost
we are non-profit we work on really
tight budgets we have to be cost
conscious but you talked about how we
kind of you know looked at the value
that we get from the model
um the the variants as well as the
amount of cost it's going to cost us and
that's how we kind of made some of those
decisions
and the third being how does this model
now really is a part of this overall
solution right where does this fit in
when is this model ready to for me to
say like yeah I'm ready to launch the
simulator for my you know 10 000
volunteers right how do I how do I think
about this uh I think there's a lot more
work that we have to do in those realm
uh to be able to really figure out like
what does success look like right when
do we say like this model is actually
solving the problem yes we can look at
metrics and say like how many volunteers
do surveys and so forth but we really
need to focus on the integration of this
model into the overall solution so
that's kind of like a high level summary
we do feel that we are in a very
privileged situation that we have the
opportunity to kind of use technology
and leverage that to be able to
contribute back to the society for the
greater good so we do fill that what's
next this is the exciting part this is
just the beginning we want to do so much
more uh we're starting with the you know
the conversation simulations which you
all saw the demo of but we also want to
create some kind of um indication and
feedback for the crisis counselors where
they can really get in-time feedback as
they are responding to this model that's
telling them hey this is an effective
message thumbs up you need to work on
this and then next actually give them
some suggestions these are what you know
effective responses would look like so
they are actually going through this
ongoing coaching and getting better at
like responding to crisis that's you
know some of the next things that we
want want to do the risk assessment that
Mateo talked about it's fairly
complicated and to do that manually and
to then I mean it's a big cognitive
overload so we're like also looking at
mechanisms where can we use AI to
analyze the conver the conversation and
the message content and continuously
like make an assessment you know is this
a low risk is this conversation
escalating to a high risk and make
decisions around prioritizing those
conversations or matching these textures
to the you know a right responders or
the right clinical stuff right so really
looking at efficiencies there where the
overall goal being can we get the people
in crisis the right level of help at the
right time that is that is the of the
essence and then you know we want to
also overall figure out how are these
conversations like kind of almost like
post analysis of our conversations is
how did we do where can we get better as
an organization where can we get better
as you know people who are part out of
this solution and so forth so we have a
lot of exciting plans and we need help
and there is various ways you can help
us a quick plug here we are hiring
machine learning and data engineers and
you can visit our website to see what
other open roles we have
can also become a crisis counselor or
volunteer your time with us in being a
thought partner in a solution or
advising us for different ml type of you
know things that we have on our plans so
there's many ways you can help us and
last but not the least you know I talked
about me being a volunteer and I
volunteer as a crisis counselor so can
you and give back to the community it's
not only that you're helping these
people in crisis but you're yourself
learning all these coping skills that
are absolutely useful life skills for
yourself for your friends for your
family and then you can be that person
in your family that's that's helping
everyone
and with that I welcome you to join us
in this battle against mental health
that's that's happening globally so we
can fight this together thank you
foreign
[Music]